un acteur de la grande distribution ici
présent à déclaré le 12 septembre sur
France Inter je cite sur le carburant
comme j'achète et je revends je ne peux
pas revendre à perte pour pratiquer le
juste prix j'en ai pas le droit
contrairement à Total énergie par
exemple fin de citation elle écoute des
acteurs économiques le gouvernement a
donc annoncé que les distributeurs de
carburant pourraient être autorisés à
vendre à perte dès le début du mois de
décembre pour une durée de 6 mois cette
disposition sera intégrée dans le texte
initial du projet de loi qui nous sera
soumis elle devrait pleinement
satisfaire ce qui ne se prive pas de
dire dans les médias la main sur le cœur
qu'il dirige une ONG qui aimerait tant
baisser les prix mais que la loi les en
empêche
[Musique]
nos entreprises ne sont pas fabriquées
pour faire de la vente à perte d'accord
nous ferons pas de vente à perdre sur le
carburant comme vous le savez nous
n'avons pas le droit de revendre à perte
c'est un principe important il ne faut
d'ailleurs pas trop ouvrir cette boîte
de Pandore là au risque de fragiliser à
la fois l'équilibre des filières et de
fragiliser l'équité territoriale entre
les consommateurs donc en ce qui nous
concerne nous ou groupe Carrefour nous
n'a puisque nous ne pouvons pas nous
concerter vous le savez nous n'avons pas
vocation et nous n'avons pas nous ne
vendrons pas à perte nous continuerons à
faire des opérations à prix coûtant
parce que nous ne pouvons pas vendre à
perdre parce que si je me mets avant à
perte de l'essence je fragilise
l'ensemble de l'équilibre que je viens
de vous décrire donc nous continuerons à
nous battre avec des opérations à prix
coûtant mais notre modèle ne nous permet
pas de vendre à perte on comprend la
démarche édouable du gouvernement mesure
exceptionnelle contexte exceptionnel
mais la réalité économique c'est que en
fait on aura on va pas l'utiliser cette
cette possibilité là parce qu'à un
moment si on fait ça on va augmenter le
prix des pâtes donc on n'est pas
complètement cinglé donc bien évidemment
on nous propose le dispositif mais vous
pensez bien que en plus il y a là pour
le coup je vous parlais de la distorsion
de concurrence avec l'action on est dans
les territoires et on a on n'a aucun
intérêt à tuer le petit pompiste qui
pourra pas évidemment le faire